all right guys
bang bang i've got my friends from quick
node here hello how are both of you
this is the first two-person interview
that we've done in the new studio
so you guys are uh our uh the the guinea
pigs we're gonna hopefully
this works um let's just talk about the
uh
quick node story right and i think just
kind of starting there and that'll lead
us into some of the data infrastructure
that's actually happening in crypto
uh um walk me through kind of your guy's
background
to get to actually starting quick note
right what you guys are very technical
right very kind of well-versed in terms
of uh
of a lot of this computational power and
infrastructure so like what did you guys
do
before we get there sure uh so
you know alex co-founded a managed
hosting company like back in 2001 maybe
even earlier you still mess around with
it early early internet stuff
and um you know we we built out a
company that was managing thousands of
servers
in like over 10 data centers around the
world
so like we got awesome
experience on how to be like on the
provider side and how to build global
networks
manage like all different stacks of
software
um then you know there's different
projects within that company
you know with regards to like video
encoding
ad serving we got to work with a really
broad range of customers
um 20 was it like 2015 we started
building
our content delivery network uh because
you know
people started the internet started
being more media rich
and you needed faster speeds you
couldn't wait for
your server in new york you know if
somebody's living across the atlantic
it'd take forever to load a video you
know if the video was hosted
in the united states so what we do is
we'd clone that video
over to somewhere in europe so they
would
you know the download speeds are a lot
quicker um
and that's that experience we we decided
to bring into quick note because
um as that company that tech was very
valuable
a company called comodo ssl acquired
that company
and as as that uh as we were
transitioning out of that
um this was around 2017 2018
we got really intrigued with what smart
contracts could enable
and uh you know we we knew what bitcoin
was
back from 2013 mount cox days you know
we
bought some bitcoin like 300 sold at a
thousand uh
it's silly to think about that now but
um
you know so we're like all right so
let's let's let's buy an ens domain name
or like like maybe
maybe like some of these token sales
were really interesting um
and we tried to interact with like my
ether wallet at the time
metamask like the very very early
versions of it
and we noticed that when when one of
these like
popular uh token sales like 0x for
example
uh it crashed the myetherwallet servers
it crashed
the metamask servers
and um we're like well this is no way
for
web 3 which is like this network of
blockchains
to to grow and so like how do we help
how do we take our experience and how do
we help
this ecosystem expand grow develop
and we're like well who who better to
build web three infrastructure
than us who have been in we've seen the
transition from web one
to web two we've contributed to a lot of
open source software and a lot a lot of
businesses uh that that are on web 2
today
um how do we help web3 um
so and so really the idea was like the
experience you guys had
uh in terms of low latency and and all
that computational infrastructure you
previously built for almost two decades
it sounds like right
when you got to crypto was like
essentially not there right like it was
just
everything would crash it couldn't
handle you know large uh volumes and
then also
um it sounds like as you got deeper and
deeper into this you realize like one we
probably can just build the
infrastructure but two also there's all
kinds of things that are unlocked with
better performance
uh in terms of actually connected to the
blockchain is that fair sure enough yeah
so we basically took all the experience
that we were gathered during
uh especially during our um cdn time you
know
we learned a lot we understood what what
latency translated into conversions
for customers we understood how to up to
optimize
certain layers of the business and
infrastructure and
software to maximize through you know
throughput and to
to to have the absolute lowest latency
in the business and so we took all that
and we applied it here because
as dmitry pointed out we were we saw the
transition from web one to web two and
went into web three uh in the beginning
of 2018 for example
and what's web 3 really it's you know
web one was read only web 2 was read and
write
web 3's ability to to verify you know
and so we saw there's a there's a lot of
that what he
what he described and we we understood
that we could bring this experience over
with our team
and build something that people will
need going forward so initially that was
like
dedicated nodes uh that that helped to
transact
on blockchain but that had limitations
um which eventually grew into this
our quick note api product uh which we
released in february 2020
that then completely took off everybody
observed it and started using it we we
grew like 1100
in three months and so it was uh it was
we understood we had a market fit right
yeah and so when you think today
um the main chains that you support are
uh
ethereum uh matic uh what else
x die x die and this is pretty much the
main three
uh no we also support optimism optimism
yep finance function finance smart chain
okay
so here's something that's fascinating
to me is uh i'm gonna call them smart
contract platforms
ethereum binance chain uh and matic and
when we look at that stuff uh it feels
like
ethereum's the one that everyone knows
right and that's kind of got like the
um when people think of smart contract
platform they think of ethereum
right so it's got the the mind share uh
but
binance smart chain and matic you know i
i should start by saying i'm an investor
in the company right so
we've had a lot of conversations about
this um are popular as well
right and so is this a world where like
these
chains are actually just competing on
technical infrastructure and like
who can create the most innovation who
has the fastest throughput speed who has
the lowest cost fees
and like it really is uh kind of this
like race to
zero on fees right maybe it doesn't
actually ever get to zero but
there's definitely like the
commoditization um across these
various smart uh contract uh platforms
so there's there's a balance there's a
balance you have to achieve and and
this was most prominent recently when
the
fee fees on ethereum mainnet skyrocketed
it was just
really expensive to move anything around
um
people started looking for alternatives
and you basically you know you sacrifice
some decentralization and and thus some
security
uh for doing something but if it's like
every you know
transactional stuff not uh
like all important governance stuff yeah
you can you can do it
layer two is is the solution and it's
not like you know you don't sacrifice
much um it's just a trade-off and again
more and more uh people are starting to
realize that the future is multi-chain
you know you might have your your
governance contracts
on ethereum because yeah it's expensive
but you know it's worth to have that
security to make sure that
this is governing your entire
organization uh but
the everyday transactions if you're
moving you know a couple of dollars
around you moves the tokens around
that stuff can be done with you know
with security with confidence on a layer
to like finance
uh like matic um like x-die um and then
we're looking forward to seeing what you
know what people build with the optimism
uh technology and so really the idea is
uh
a decentralized smart contract platform
is really important for governance like
you said right so there's a reason
for decentralization in that standpoint
you wanna have almost what i call like
democratic governance right as many
people
participating as possible and uh as
least concentration or kind of single
point of failure as possible
but if i simply just want to make a
trade i don't necessarily need all that
decentralization right
i actually want the most efficiency that
i can gain and sometimes
uh the decentralized systems are much
less efficient
sometimes for certain things they may be
more efficient right there's a whole
other thing
uh but if i simply want to just get the
efficiency
lower fees faster throughput then
decentralization doesn't really matter
in that situation
fair sure okay uh explain to people the
difference between
uh matic finance smart chain and
ethereum just from like a technical you
know high level
uh in terms of block times and like why
are these others
maybe more efficient without
decentralization as kind of
the core linchpin so uh ethereum
currently is proof of work
uh it's got about 15 12 or to 12 second
block times
uh matic has um validators
uh and there's there's like a three
point system
where where they're validating uh and
then
the block times are also shorter uh
quick quicker rather
and binance smart chain also val also
validator concept
with three second block times so you
know a lot of
recently a lot of d5 platforms have
moved to finance smart chain
because binance you know just because
they're they're uh
an exchange and and they have all that
that deep you know financial pull
but um it also helps to have like order
books
update every three seconds because you
want to make those trades you want
compared to ethereum being 12 to 15
seconds exactly okay
and and and they they've made the fees
uh you know less expensive so
again if you're you're building a wallet
app a decentralized wallet app you'll
you know you'll have the main governance
on ethereum you'll have the transaction
like
moving tokens around on finance smart
chain you'll have your nfts moving
around on
polygon uh there's a there's a big move
of nfts and like media platforms moving
to polygon
um so they're you know again future is
multi-chain
we're looking to support that um you
know we're we're looking to expand
the chains we support because yeah
there's
it's good to give developers choice you
know when they're building up
an application you know you know don't
force them to use ethereum
because ethereum is not perfect neither
you know i don't think any any platform
is perfect
and so when they have that choice they
can choose and pick and choose and put
how we how we say like legos together to
build their application
so the way i describe quick node is it's
basically like
amazon aws but for blockchains
right which i think is like a fair thing
how does the product work itself right
so if i'm a developer i come in i go to
the quick node website like
what do i choose from and like what is
actually technically happening
okay i mean you just sign up for either
a free or nine hour account for example
as a developer you get an endpoint right
away within five minutes you'll be able
to take that endpoint
plug it into your code and you're ready
to transact
i think great example of that was
customer of ours for example doing
analytics
came to our site in the middle of night
four in the morning had an outage under
self-hosted nodes able to sign up and
within five to ten minutes they were
back online without having to speak to
anybody
and so what we built is a self self
self-serve platform
that that customers could come without
um having to speak to anybody just
sign up and go and and then um to add to
that on the back end
we're running uh like dozens of clusters
of super super powerful
uh ethereum binance smart chain matic
nodes
and a node is a peer-to-peer piece of
software which maintains an up-to-date
copy of the ledger
and it talks to other nodes on the
network miners validators
it sees when a new block arrives and
then it it builds that database and
then we have these middle layers like a
routing
middle layer which if you're making a
request
from the netherlands you're going to hit
a node cluster in the netherlands if
you're making a request from london
you're going to hit a node cluster in
london
china singapore san francisco new york
so by bringing the data closer to the
users
you minimize network hops you reduce
latency make things
quicker snappier and as alex mentioned
that's experience we bring over from our
from our cdn experience
you know companies like yahoo aol amazon
they invested
hundreds of thousands of dollars into
research into human psychology
that faster speeds results in
happiness to like for people when
something happens fast
people get excited and that results in
them coming back to your website
or using your application more making a
purchase
taking a call to action so we understand
how important speed
and like blockchain is notorious for its
slowness
so if you know our platform makes you
know if we can make it just a little a
little bit faster or in some cases a lot
a bit faster
you know some customers came to us
they're like hey we switched to you guys
and we saw
100x improvement in in in our polling
speeds
and we're like wow so this is fantastic
so i can say this you guys can't say
this
uh because people that you're bragging
but uh when i was doing the diligence to
research uh to invest
uh and researching all this i'd go talk
to customers and they were like listen
it's like not even close
right in terms of a lot of the other
services in the space just there is that
latency
and they maybe just be focused on things
that's not the most important thing
they're building
i think given your guys background you
really understand the importance of
latency and you're looking for customers
that want
a lack of latency right and so uh
because of that speed what are customers
actually doing is there one or two
examples that you have of like
hey a customer's doing x with our
infrastructure that uh can highlight to
people like why this is so important
from
uh just a pure like infrastructure
interacting with these blockchains
sure um i think you might like to talk
about this a lot so
go for it yeah yeah yeah no we have the
just here the great part about being at
the infrastructure level is that
everybody
who's working with blockchain
interacting with blockchain needs your
service so
we we work with a bunch of projects
across the board um
anyone anyone from like traditional uh
finance systems who are looking to
interact with blockchain to uh
decentralized finance systems
and professional traders who are um who
are looking to get like
the fastest information uh the latest
block information you know what happened
to the smart contract what happened
to this una swap pair uh what what
happened on um
on uh any one of these decentralized
exchanges
but more moreover uh there's there's a
lot of people looking for
the mempool data uh and the the mempool
for those who don't understand is the
mempool stuff is
that's what happens before transactions
get mined
and accepted as truth into the
blockchain um
and there's there's about you know a 10
to 12 second period where people's
transactions get entered into the
mempool and then miners get to choose
which transactions they mine into the
next block
and what happens there let's say a
transaction is submitted
somewhere in new york and it's mine in
its mind somewhere in new york by the
time
that propagates and by propagates it
goes from one node to another node to
another node and makes tops
to a node in china it might be every
anywhere from several milliseconds to
several
seconds and that's very valuable time
especially for
in the finance sector where they need to
make these split-second decisions on
what their next move is
so what we've done is we've created uh
we're aggregating the memphis data from
all the nodes we run
all over the world we have over 12
locations where
in multiple clouds so basically anywhere
in the world the transaction enters the
mempool
we then broadcast it to whoever's
subscribing to that data
and they're paying as like a
subscription they're paying
they're paying for that for every
transaction that they're subscribed to
they're paying for that request like to
receive that piece of data got it and so
when we think about this
uh you have not only infrastructure
right like what i consider just
you guys have done the work you've built
out infrastructure now i can come in i
can basically plug in through your
infrastructure and i can communicate
with these blockchains i can get the
actual kind of copy of the blockchain or
whatever
uh but also you got a ton of data right
and so maybe talk a little bit like
the data importance versus the
infrastructure importance and like
how you think about like the business
evolving over time
yeah i mean um so if you look at the
relationship between civil and uh
robinhood for example
there's a lot of you know business there
so what we what we able to gather is all
these transactions that are going on our
network
and all this data that we're able to
share perhaps
uh with uh with someone that could be
very
very valuable specifically for like
large funds who are
executing on things i need to have more
insights um
and research companies you know to
better understand the landscape
um of of uh what's happening before the
rest of the world sees it right
and so that data piece could be very
very valuable in if
by our estimations somewhere in 10
billion dollars a year range
you know um over the next five years or
so
and so um that piece is is
very not a lot of people talking about
that piece specifically but um
we think that that piece of the business
is huge you know we
we've been having certain conversations
with certain funds and things like that
um with uh with with ceos that are
interested in the data that could
utilize this data
to make better decisions on their end
got it and when you think about
um the infrastructure really it's kind
of a two-step business right you have to
have the infrastructure in order for you
guys to get the data
but you're monetizing the infrastructure
itself and then
if there's this opportunity to do data
as well that's really additive to the
business
it's not kind of an either or decision
not at all
yeah yeah um what do you think is the
biggest
challenge going forward really when you
think about all right we've got all this
work to do
we're going to keep doing this what's
the biggest challenge for the business
to to keep to keep up with demand and
and that's a good problem it's a great
problem it's like every you know
startups dream
to have a problem but it's to keep up
with demand and keep meeting customers
expectations like and their expectations
keep growing
data day to day you know when you know
there's there's some people that were
querying maybe like five blocks at a
time for data now they're querying like
chunks of thousands of blocks and they
need that data in a millisecond
so like we're we're working on different
ways to index it we're using
special um special hardware that's like
super snappy like super super fast disks
to be able to access this data
work we have a caching layer that stores
some of this data in memory
again to to improve speeds so
you know with the the great thing about
um again
infrastructure layer such a wide range
of customers we get
so much data from our customers around
how they're using it what their use case
is um
maybe perhaps that in touch up enough on
on the the range of our customers is
we also have nft platforms that are
minting nfts
we have customers that are building uh
blockchain gaming ecosystems they're
doing esports tournaments that are our
blockchain
uh backed so things like in-game skins
and and certain like prizes
um there's uh there's people building
universal basic income
there's another project called pull
together which is a no-loss lottery i
think it's one of the
craziest inventions because uh people
basically buy a ticket
for the lottery uh it goes it gets lent
out into a decentralized lending
platform which earns interest
and then one person wins the interest
and everybody gets their money back
like it's fantastic no and this happens
this happens trustlessly automatically
how often do they like do like a drawing
they they do a drawing i
i don't know once a week or something
something like that but like it's an
amazing concept that you can have you
can do this without
an intermediary like you're not buying a
lottery ticket from the state of florida
or anything this is just
it's a global lottery that's trustless
and automatic
and you don't lose money and you don't
lose money somebody just somebody wins
some interest
to win win it's win-win yeah and i guess
because you're really getting everyone's
interest
it's not just the interest that you
would have gotten going by and doing it
yourself right
you're contributing to this big pool the
big pool earns a ton of interest all at
once
and then basically somebody wins that as
part of the lottery it yeah it's
incredible
yeah it's wild um one of the things that
uh fascinates me about this is as you
guys have chosen new blockchains to
support
uh they've turned into uh we'll call
spectacles to be nice
uh which is um you say hey we're gonna
support something
uh when you choose to support it uh that
community gets really excited but also
other people start to pay attention and
so just like
what is the process for vetting these
deciding who to work with
um and kind of like how does that work
and through like prioritization
yeah so i mean for us it's all about
we're all about community right we would
like to build
a community we like to support the
community and we understand for this to
grow
for everybody to benefit the community
piece needs to exist so we always look
at when someone a foundation
for example like mattock approaches us
or we approach them every time it's a
different story
usually we will we'll look at their
github how active are they how many
developers they have how
how involved they're with the whole
ecosystem are we helping the whole
ecosystem
and then we'll make a decision whether
or not we're going to take our eyes off
our roadmap
and add them to um to to add them to our
network
and for us it's very important that
whoever we are to our network
that they are contributing to the whole
ecosystem they have a
sort of a sandbox environment for the
developers
you know public endpoints that they
could subsidize so that's a very
important piece for us because we
understand we're not only helping us
we're also helping the whole community
and the whole ecosystem to grow
and yeah that's pretty much it yeah
we're also listening
a lot to our customers and customers
basically tell us what they want you
know customers can come say when are you
guys going to support matic we're like
okay we'll we'll look into it like where
are you going when are you guys we're
going to support
uh xdi or uh bsc and like
this this is like such valuable feedback
because when you when you get enough of
these requests you're like
maybe you know maybe they're on to some
um and and also
like uh when you know we've been in the
space since
uh late 2017 we've we've built the brand
uh it's a known brand and
uh you know when when a company chooses
to partner with us
it's it's celebrated very very well
especially in the community because it's
like
this this particular foundation is
serious about supporting their
developers and giving them choice
giving them uh robust infrastructure to
be able to build these
you know global scale apps because these
the the foundations they're
they don't have the kind of teams with
with the kind of experience that
you know quicknote brings to the table
so being able to bootstrap
um you know this high performance
scalable uh
node with three infrastructure uh is
like super super valuable to these
people
and um it's very well received by by the
community it's celebrated like you know
almost like a token listing um like yeah
it's it's crazy it's crazy right that's
crazy well i mean
you know we we we we were accepted into
the y combinator
um uh
batch for the winter and you know they
pumped out instacart they pumped out uh
coinbase for example
and i'm looking at coinbase's story and
they started out just selling bitcoin
and then they added ethereum and then
they added litecoin and then they and
other
now they have like i don't know it's
like 20 30 assets so i'm like
this is very very much parallel to i
feel like what quicknote is doing you
know
we're not we're not just dedicated to
ethereum we support bitcoin and
we support six six uh chains and ten
different networks at this point
and this is just just the beginning
what's up guys bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com pomp
again blockfy.com go check it out and
let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it it's
fascinating to me too
that um you guys have done a lot of this
uh you've also raised capital so maybe
talk a little bit about that
but like outside of like the hardcore
development community many people don't
know about you
right which is almost like a testament
to you've found the right people that to
know about you like who cares if
everyone knows right it's just like the
people who are the customers they all
know
and when they think of hey i need
infrastructure that's got a little
latency like bam i got a quick note
right right and so was that intentional
or did that just kind of naturally
happen
that was just a natural progression
really um i don't think it was
intentional what do you think i mean we
just try to build the best possible
product
and and and you know that's why i love
you guys you guys i don't know it's
like the right thing we know we had to
build we had to build the right thing
that
that worked well that people would love
the user experience was absolutely the
best
and we took all the things what not to
do from the previous companies
and we applied it here we had the right
formula you know we learned
on our mistakes we learned we i remember
being in the late 90s being in high
school coming home
before aol you know going to rsc and all
this i remember all this
progression from web one to web two
understanding how it changed the world
and i wish i was older you know older
back then
to understand what i was being involved
in you know and now being here with
experience with with all that to be able
to take all that and to apply it here
it's just a piece of cake we know
exactly what people want we're listening
to our community we're listening to our
customer
and we drive for we're driving the the
need from within the company
and so like i don't think anybody else
works harder than us you know we
we're there in the office building 12
hours a day 14 hours a day nobody's
sleeping you know
seven days a week so we understand i
know you guys are
well talked about the fundraise in terms
of uh what was the thought process you
went to yc
uh and also did the fundraise at either
one of you which whoever wants to talk
about it
yeah i think uh i'll start off and you
could show up sure
so we we started a fundraise sometime in
in november
and then we got a during during the
initial stages of it we got accepted to
yc
and um that was very exciting yc is a
you know great process to go through
um we learned a lot and um but we
decided like
you know yc recommends not to start any
fundraising during
yc until the demo day since we're
already in the process
we sort of just left you know we sort of
just ran with it
and that was that was great because you
know in the beginning
um we got a lot of like hey what the
hell you guys talking about why doesn't
amazon just come in and do it you know
we don't believe in that there's a need
for this product
into towards the end you know towards so
that that was that was november
by january we had so much interest in
our company
that we had like literally probably like
over 200 companies
coming up like hey let us write your
check what's the valuation and what's
this
you know can we get in and um you know
you're an investor we
met with you and um it was no brainer
no brainer you know it was it was one of
those
processes that that i think yco's helped
us a lot through you know like
as we were taking on some of these some
of these um investors
we want to make a strategic partnership
with each one of them you know we
understood you as a strategic piece to
it you know you know very
um listen to we have 50 million
followers etc like you you'll definitely
help spread the word
you know like we had michael erington
who who was
um who actually convinced us to stay
with yc
because we're in the beginning like do
we really need it you know we sort of
have the experience
but he was like hey you guys don't
understand what it is you definitely
want to be part of it
we're like hey for sure you know we'll
go with it then we have like alexis
rohanian you know like
he brings in so much 76 776 fund yeah
he brings in so much so much experience
and every two weeks
him and his team are with us for an hour
at a time
we're going through things we're
strategizing you know we're going
through everything like
he's been amazing throughout the whole
process so um
but you know and we sort of like so
hashkey's one of the
one of the investors for them we were
like what do they bring to the table
well they're asian you know one of the
biggest asians invested into blockchain
space
they have a lot of uh blockchain
companies in their portfolio
you know we sort of picked them for that
for that environment and so like we sort
of
put put a team together for an
investment that could drive us through
to the next level and today i think we
are we're we're very happy with our
partnerships have asked for for better
partners
absolutely amazing softbank softbank
brings in so much experience the
opportunity fund as you know has been
created for
um you know um
sort of uh you know the black founders
and
one of our founders happens to be austin
he's uh he's half black have
um uh saturn south american and uh
he was able to you know connect us with
soul bank and we're able to work with
them and we love that team
you know them too they we get on the
monthly calls with them
strategizing accounting pieces you know
how to how to structure certain deals
how to close certain customers how to
grow the business from within
and you know how to focus on the culture
also i mean 776 funds these guys
also they want to diversify our our team
they want more women on our team
we actually just recently hired our
first woman
uh for uh for uh for hr and customer
success yes
i mean she's she's gonna be like the
mother of the week yeah
we needed a mother company and so like
we've been trying to hire like from all
different backgrounds first of all we
all immigrants you know like
all four four co-founders uh three
co-founders
are immigrants you know he's from uh
russia i'm from ukraine
the other one is from from germany
manuel cruz and so like we understand
the process you know we understand the
importance of diversity within the team
and so for us like what we are building
is exactly that we understand that you
know they can be just a bunch of white
dudes sitting
and uh building another facebook that
needs to be somebody that that
understands
the the paint points that that people go
through and sort of that that's
that's the sort of company we're
building yeah i mean it's fantastic
what has been the uh biggest surprise in
building the business over the last uh
couple of months
i don't know the amount of the amount of
demand
i mean we opened up our gate gates and
just people is flooding in
we have so much so much um interest in
the business and so many foundations are
coming to us it's like please take our
money and
and add us to the platform and i think
that's that's been
the biggest surprise from my perspective
yeah i think it's it's the number of
diverse projects that are building on
the platform and
and that we're able to facilitate you
know they're giving us this feedback
like oh your platform's so easy to use
we were able to get started real quick
um and you know it's there just again
there's companies building
um like new ways of governance there's
new ways of voting
meritocracy uh just all all across the
board
uh and then and then you know you have
you have some of these
large financial corporations with like
billions in crypto under management
they're also they also need this service
um you know uh banks and
and and hedge funds they i think we're
we're just
at the very very beginning even even
though there's been so much progress
even from when we entered the space in
2017 until now
um you know it's so much easier to build
a decentralized application or a
blockchain powered application
um and like what alex had mentioned like
back in the 90s how difficult it was to
build a website
but then you had you know companies like
amazon come along and make all that
process like streamlined and made it so
easy so when you when you think about
running
uh node infrastructure you know you
probably have to go read a bunch of
documentation you have to learn how to
use a command line you gotta go
do your research on what kind of specs
you need for your cloud server
or you just go to quick node you sign up
and and you go and then you know there's
complex
the complexity increases as you scale up
uh do you need two nodes you need a load
balancer in front of it how to keep the
data consistent
between you know the different different
types of nodes
but being able to support such a wide
range of projects
um is just it motivates us every day to
come come to work and just like
build the best possible product and make
our customers happy if you look
for like five or ten years how big can
this get and like what does this
morph into right when you're just gonna
look at like what's the natural
progression of this
web web web three every single
application we use
today will have some element of
blockchain built into it
so you know you think of you think of
middlemen you
first thing comes to mind is like real
estate you need you need a agent you
need an escrow agent you need
title insurance once you have d's on the
blockchain
you can govern a real estate transaction
and buy a smart contract you don't need
a middleman you don't need a third party
you don't need escrow you know
one side sends usdc for example the
other side
submits the deed they submit the title
and the title
is governed by a system that keeps it
honest so you need you don't need title
insurance then
it eliminates friction it eliminates
that trust layer
so when both conditions are met the
smart contract
that lives on the blockchain it's
completely independent
of anyone's control then just swaps it
and
yeah and and that could be tied down to
like the keypad
uh changing you know changing the code
so the person can get access to the
property
um that's that's where we see this going
well you know
we see was it uh bit clout but
yeah so social networks moving into into
blockchain
every single application i mean
everything from
uh from universities issuing diploma
diplomas on the blockchain so you can
then
you know imagine you you you're asked to
vote
on something that you actually have a
merit in
like only if you have a phd in medicine
can you vote
on on a certain on a particular uh issue
so that kind of stuff that's what that's
what blockchain enables that's the kind
of future
um that we see so i mean
global scale this is the next this is
like the new the next iteration the next
version of the internet
yeah it's pretty wild to think about
right
like if you just think about like all
right like where we are headed is
[ __ ] nuts
compared to where we've been and uh
today we look at like cars right and
it's like wait we used to ride horses
like there is that element of like you
know you said like title insurance like
all these things that aren't going to be
needed
you're like you did what before like
there's physical paper involved
and now people are going to be like okay
like obviously the digital system's so
much better you're telling me people
literally didn't think that was gonna be
true yeah okay
man get get gen z to send an
international wire
they'll they they won't be able to do it
yeah of course not
they want cash app they want square they
want you know it's
just peer-to-peer like here's an address
here's my address
send send me the tokens that's why
companies like venmo and whatever exists
today you know to be able to do that
but i think you know primarily if you
look at like if you're looking to
purchase a property somewhere abroad for
example
say spain right so you're looking to buy
a home in spain the amount of
bureaucracy and crap you need to go
through i went through that so i
understand like to
from your bank to send the money there
they need to exchange it from dollars to
euro
you need to you need to prove that this
money is coming from you
then you need you know you need to go
through this whole process and the way
the real estate is done there
globally you could have one global
system that that sort of
eliminates all that like if if you want
to send your end 500 bucks on a sunday
yeah you know in in in the traditional
way
the banks are closed you're unable to do
it they're going to charge your nominal
leg
you just went through it you have to go
a bunch of kyc stuff you know because
russia is in
you know whatever yeah like it's crazy
you can't even use your own money
during the certain times same thing in
the banks here like if you're making a
large transaction
whether it's a deposit deposit or you're
withdrawing that you need to tell them
what
why why is this happening this is your
money yeah so so
just you mentioned transferring money
but like a a small error controversy was
like
recently vitalik was airdropped some
like a couple of billion dollars of this
sheep at token uh and he was able to
donate that
to an indian uh relief fund
you know because of the covet stuff
happening in india and that he was able
to do that without anybody's permission
for like 100 like it was like 12
or something in fees maybe maybe 100 in
fees but like
a billion dollars moved across the world
any to any point
without anyone's permission uh for a
very small
amount do we know if they um went ahead
and
liquidated it or did they hold on to the
sheba token
would have we would have to look at this
yeah we'd have to look right i don't
know
it's transparent like if you want to
know what happened to it just go look at
the transaction yeah
which is like the best part about it
right it is because now all of a sudden
like one kudos to him for doing that
right uh two
is you can literally see what they do
with it yeah and so it's like pretty
crazy to think it's not just about the
transaction itself it's the fact that he
got it
right then once he got it right what'd
they do then he donated it okay
now once they get the donation what do
they do with it it's transparent like
there's a whole bunch of ramifications
in just that one
um kind of mechanism that you're like
wait a minute this was not possible
before
yeah like look what happened in haiti
you know they're in the during the whole
thing like bunch of stuff went there
it never went to the people it rotted it
got stolen
you know and and this is exactly what
it's for and metallic by the way he
burned the rest of the sheba
you know completely you know i think it
was like six billion dollars worth yeah
yeah he burns he just burned it you know
he donated most of it
and whatever here left he burned it and
he left the message like
don't don't air drop me these tokens
without my permission i don't want to be
responsible or something like that but
he
he was very like philosophical about it
yeah he he basically
because what they tried to give it to
him so that it would seem more
legitimate because the creator of
ethereum held the tokens
so basically he was like i don't want
these and get rid of it
yeah it's i mean it's fascinating not
very many people who say they donated a
billion dollars to something
even who's it sandeep from from one of
the co-founders of matic
uh he released a tweet he's like i can't
sit down sit around anymore i have to do
something i have to help you know the
people in india and
within within like a couple of hours
he created a multi-sig uh wallet and had
the whole
global crypto community donate to to
this cause so
on a philanthropic uh philanthropic
level
you had a global crypto community like
get together and
and like create this fun to help
something you know
in a different part of the world like in
a day like that just
you know you you could try with gofundme
or whatever but
i think this this was just um a great
example of
a the crypto community coming together
but also uh the application of
you know moving moving funds across
borders without permissions without any
kind of like
red you know bureaucracy or red tape
i mean it's crazy to think about right
what are you guys most excited about
moving forward
uh everything every every every day
every day something something new
something pops up you know projects like
i said except projects signing up and
being able to to support them
um i'm looking forward to see what
optimism is gonna it's gonna optimize
you guys keep talking about that so
you're super excited about that team
what they're doing um
can't talk much about it but i think
that's one of the projects i'm really
excited about um
going forward about you definitely that
you know
we have we have a couple of chains we
sign a couple of new
new um contracts with foundations with
new chains that we're gonna
we're gonna develop um you know we're
hiring uh
i was gonna say who are we trying to
hire we're hiring we're hiring across
the board we're scaling the team you
know we've got devop
devops engineers front end uh front-end
developers
um bracket engineers yeah
then then we have like um technical
support engineers
um we had good amount of additions to
our team like we we grew from like
you know a five people team um like a
month and a half ago
to 12 people team and we continue to
expand our team
so if what we look i i'm looking to to
build the culture i'm excited about
building the culture in the company
and and sort of this foundation of quick
note that will grow into its own
departments
in in near future and so we just
recently hired somebody from
tiktok and uh previously worked with
facebook they ran a you know
a sales team there that's that was
excited to join our team and we're
excited to
to be working with him he's an amazing
individual with
with with with a great like view of what
what this could become
and so i enjoy personally work with him
every day and sort of attacking
different angles of the market
how we could you know how we could
attack enterprise how we could um
improve uh improve our sales process for
for you know developer
uh platform and and all of this like and
sort of like
looking into what we could build
together in the future and sort of
segment it to into smaller teams that
like one team will attack
uh the chain market one team i will
attack the developer market one team
will attack
the the found you know the foundations
and um
and the whole business sector and so
that's very exciting i think working
with that is
yeah so to finish my point is like well
we've been able to accomplish with a
team of like
five six people now that we have this
additional funding and we have this
momentum
what we'll be able to accomplish with
like a double the size of the team
that's what really excites me like we
we're gonna 10x the performance of the
tech
make it way more faster way more
reliable we're gonna expand
the the product uh we're gonna expand it
into different markets
you know and now with with some of these
bigger players
uh catching on catching starting to ride
the wave you know being able to provide
services to to like bank like mainstream
banks and
mainstream uh investor and hedge funds
uh
that that that's that's what i'm like
most excited about i think you guys are
on to something
for sure thanks you've been you've been
a great help man it's it's amazing it's
so like i said we have we have the best
investors we have
the best partners that we're working
with so it's it's great
i think also what's it what's really
exciting is to see some of these
you know big players like cash up for
example had a conversation with cash up
the other day
and they sort of understand that d5 is
going to put them out of business this
is their words like we understand deep
is going to put us out of business
so what we do and we create a team
inside to sort of put us
put ourselves out of business before
that happens and so they're
really smart people they understand that
this is going to change the world this
is going to change the way people
transact
the way you use money and the next
generation will no longer be able to
you know to stand for the the previous
you know standards that we had growing
up
and so like you know companies like that
that understand it and we still start
early on that they're building something
next and something cool
that for you know for the next
generation so yeah that's super exciting
you know that's awesome yeah right that
you can uh you can participate there
uh before i let you guys go i several
same three questions so i'm gonna do it
you both answer
uh each uh individually uh most
important book you've ever read
hard things uh hard things about how
things by uh ben horowitz
however credit twice i still come back
to it very often
yeah that's a great one uh that book and
high output management
by andy grove that's another great one
you guys are well read
uh second question is sleep schedule
comes from our friends over at eight
sleep i sleep on one every night
it's cold as [ __ ] sleep perfectly i feel
like i'm like a convert of the sleep
religion what's your guys sleep schedule
oh that's not a good start we actually
actually had a friend who who was
uh i guess he was he was trying to like
he was advertising this cold bed
idea to us and and uh you know maybe
we'll go out and try that
sleep schedule it's try to get six to
seven hours
um i mean you we we're working crazy
crazy
like super intense days so about like
like 9 10 rolls around
i'm exhausted yeah i'm 12 to six
midnight and six six six a.m i'm up yoga
and then 6 30 6 45 i'm with the computer
working
really yeah so you can go 12 to 6 is
you're perfectly fine
yeah totally fine oh man i need it it's
all about the mushrooms you know that
you got the
the rishi the you know cordyceps
cordyceps
you put that in your smoothie it gives
you it gives you amazing energy we're
using uh
something by uh paul stametz uh i don't
know if you know who he is he was
big yeah that guy is amazing he's like
one of the biggest mycologists in uh
in the united states uh he was in joe
rogan's uh podcast bunch of times
the guy is just like out of this world
super fascinating podcast super
fascinating and definitely watch that he
has a movie on
not netflix uh amazon prime but anyways
he has this
on fungi.com he here's this product
these products so these mushrooms mixes
that you could put into your yogurts or
whatever
incredible do you drink coffee or that
or you just use the stuff
i used to do matcha so i stopped the
caffeine during this time it's so crazy
that
you have so much energy so much
excitement working every day yeah but if
you had anything else
you you start crashing yeah i had to cut
back on the call
like i stopped coffee i switched from
full calf to
i started making my own mix of like
two-thirds decaf one-third caffeinated
okay now i'm completely off because it
was just
messing with my mind so really yeah just
maybe every once in a while i have like
essentia
green tea but i i can't do full-on
calf at least at least not not right now
because it's already
intense yeah i uh i drink two coffees a
day and i've been thinking like should i
try to
stop and i don't know if i could that
was me man that was me now we have these
these crashes you know like in the
middle of the day like [ __ ] i'm out of
energy
and i got so many things to do you know
and yes like it's messing with you
yeah it's definitely messing with you
and so you just don't do it at all and
then you're good
no no it's yeah there's good there's
good argument for that
a very good argument for that uh last
question is aliens
are you a believer or a non-believer oh
yeah we're yeah
how do we all suddenly end up here right
like that movie he saw when paul stanley
he said we all came from mushrooms like
x amount of billions years ago so the
mycelium was
is actually like this this network sort
of like quick node right
that's connecting all the trees and all
the living things around around the
forest
and all the trees and all these all
these uh plants are able to communicate
with one another and transfer nutrients
so the the trees and the plants they
they transfer nutrients
through the mushroom mycelium networks
underground
really yeah that's wild it's called the
fantastic
fungi i think it's called fantastic
fungi all right i
have to try to watch that amazing and so
that's all what's like quick note
whenever one region becomes overloaded
or unavailable we're able to transfer
that
that nutrient to the other region to the
same region on a different cloud
yeah so like we are the product of of
that you know like we are
like people people believe there's a lot
of so if you look at if you speak to
mycologists and you speak to some
scientists
everybody has their own theory on how we
came about you know but i definitely
stay more on the mushroom side because
that's a lot more compelling yeah i mean
you guys might convince me to go
get some mushrooms all right where can
we set people to find you guys on the
internet or find out more about
quicknode
quicknode.com we recently rebranded from
quik
node.io to quicknow.com the way we spoke
we had both domains
from the gecko but there was you know we
were drinking kool-aid in 2018 it was a
cool thing to do it was a cool thing to
do everybody was misspelling things
so you had both the whole time the whole
time yeah oh
we knew we knew from day one that you
know it's going to be autocorrect people
are going to want to go to the dot com
so we but we booked it from day one but
you know we were quick
and if you leave a letter out you're
faster to type it
and it was it was and uh come on that's
a shitty
answer you know you know there's there's
there's no
there's been research like uh when uh
when
if you can shorten your url uh you know
you might save like
a a hundredth of a millisecond or
something like that so
just just leave it just leaving it i
love it but it was a cool thing it was a
cool thing to do but
now that you know we're more mature
we're in a different stage of the
company
uh we're like all right let's start
let's spell it right
um especially looking five ten years
ahead you know maybe
we go ipo or something we need to have a
proper spell
all right so quicknode.com quicknode.com
quicknode.com everyone go check it out
thank you guys for doing this thanks for
having me